hi guys dr. Berg here here's the
question can I eat oatmeal on a
ketogenic diet will it Bob me out of
fat-burning okay let's talk about that
so the first thing you need to know is
that there's two types of oatmeal one is
the steel-cut I guess it's called the
Irish or Scottish oatmeal which is
unrefined and then you have the instant
oatmeal which is usually with a ton of
sugar or brown sugar okay well if you
take a look at the glycemic index still
cut it's about 55 not terribly high not
terribly low a bit too high for a
ketogenic diet though so it does tend to
turn in sugar somewhat and then you have
the instant look at 83 so that's good
that's evil without the sugar so it's
going to convert to sugar pretty fast
because it's more refined so so the more
glycemic it is the worse it is for your
weight loss okay so number one you never
want to consume the instant oatmeal you
don't want to do it and you definitely
don't want to buy that packets with the
added sugar because it's not healthy at
all as far as nutrients in oatmeal there
is a small amount of nutrients I'm not
saying it's completely avoid but it does
have something called beta glucan which
is something that is helpful for
cholesterol okay but here's the point if
you're trying to lose weight and you're
on a ketogenic diet and keeping your
carbs really low it's not a good idea to
consume oatmeal okay because it's going
to slow you down if you're not trying to
lose weight go ahead and consume but
just make sure to still cut yes it takes
longer to make but it's healthier okay
then this stuff over here alright that's
my answer
hey if you're enjoying my videos press
the subscribe button below and I will
keep you updated on the future event
thank you so much